Bees might not be your
favorite insects out there.
After all, their stings can really hurt.
Ouch!
But as far as important species go,
bees are near the top of the list.
You see, bees are critical pollinators,
meaning they're responsible
for pollinating more
than a third of the crops
that feed the world's population.
But today, bees are dying
off at record rates.
So, what would a world
without bees look like,
and what would that mean
for our global food supply?
Well, if all the bees on
Earth suddenly dropped dead
tomorrow, things wouldn't
look good for our planet.
And that's because pollination is critical
to the health of our global ecosystem.
It's what allows plants to reproduce
and grow the fruits and
vegetables humans need
for a balanced diet.
And the thing is, bees are some of
the best pollinators out there.
In fact, they've coevolved
with flowering plants
over millions of years to
become pollinating machines.
Elina Niño: Of course,
a lot of them are fuzzy,
so they have hairs,
or specialized equipment, so to speak,
where they can store pollen.
Narrator: Bees help pollinate the reported
84% of crops humans eat
that are insect-pollinated.
Globally, this accounts for a staggering
$235 billion to $577 billion
in annual food production.
Without bees and other pollinators,
supermarket shelves would hold about
half the fruits and
vegetables they have now,
transforming the produce
section from this...
to this.
We wouldn't have luxuries
like almonds, apples,
or avocados.
Niño: We would also suffer
in terms of dairy production.
We use alfalfa to feed dairy cattle,
and dairy cattle, of
course, produces the milk,
and the milk is used to produce
many dairy products that we eat.
When I talk to the kids, all the kids
are very disappointed to hear
that we might lose ice cream.
Narrator: The extinction of
bees could have a disastrous
domino effect, killing off
animals that eat those plants,
and so on up the food chain.
Luckily, humanity wouldn't
face a global famine
like you might expect.
Niño: We wouldn't
necessarily starve to death,
because there are a lot
of plants that we do eat
and we depend on that are wind-pollinated,
including, for example, wheats.
Narrator: So if the bee
apocalypse does hit,
we could still meet
the daily calorie needs
of our global population.
Our diets, however, would
suffer in major ways,
as foods that provide key
nutrients for our bodies
would become scarce and
extremely expensive.
Niño: A lot of the plants that we eat
that are dependent on animal pollination
do provide the necessary micronutrients
that improve our health.
We would probably be very sickly.
So, for example, let's just
think about citrus, right?
We would probably have issues with scurvy,
if you think about it.
I guess you could really
supplement that with vitamins,
but again, definitely
not all of the vitamins
can be as easily accessible to the body
as they are when you're
actually eating them.
Narrator: According to the
US Department of Agriculture,
the work that bees do
for US farmers is worth
about $15 billion a year, so without them,
the cost of produce would skyrocket.
Niño: Especially those who are
socioeconomically challenged,
they already have hard times
accessing the healthy foods,
so this would probably
impact them even worse.
Narrator: And we could be
closer to a bee-less future
than you might expect.
In 2018, American
beekeepers reported losing
41% of their colonies,
and worldwide, bees have been dying off
at record rates for the past decade.
Niño: Honeybees, at least in
the past, I believe, 12 years
have been declining about
up to 45% annually, in some cases.
Narrator: Scientists haven't
pinned down an exact reason
for this sudden decline
in the bee population.
However, likely reasons
are global warming,
overuse of pesticides, and
parasitic varroa mites,
which spread viruses to bee colonies.
Right now, countries around
the world are working
to monitor bee colonies and even create
new pollination methods using robots.
Niño: There are researchers
who are trying to develop
drone pollinators,
so using drone technology
to pollinate flowers.
It all would most likely be more costly.
Narrator: So, what can
the average person do
to be more bee-friendly?
Well, if you have a garden,
plant a range of flowers
so wandering bees can
have access to nectar
throughout the year.
Niño: Bees that we have
that are wild bees,
that are native bees,
a lot of them actually nest in soil,
so leaving bare ground for
those bees is really useful
if you're redoing your lawn, for example.
Providing access to water would also
be very helpful for the bees,
and reducing pesticide
input if at all possible.
Narrator: While steps
are already being taken
to save the world's bee population,
there's still a lot to be done
to protect Earth's most buzzy pollinators.